i want to talk about the um
ramifications of a woke military
yeah because the the wokeness has spread
far and wide to the point where one of
our generals is saying so what's so
wrong about reading mao and do al doing
all these things
and uh we make jokes about basic
training and you know soy is coming out
i guess
i don't know if you saw this story but
this one from the washington post
russia says it fired warning shots at a
british warship in the black sea
the uk says it didn't i don't
necessarily believe the uk
russians also say they were dropping
bombs in the path of the
of the british warship because they
entered crimean waters this freaks me
out
see the the us uh nato was doing big war
games
russia then counters with their own war
games we see
the hms trent royal navy going through
the bosphorus strait only a few weeks
ago then
the hms defender entering crimean waters
which russia is claiming its own so it's
occupied waters
doesn't matter who you think belong it
belongs to we are dangerously close to
conflict
china came out and said that they will
join russia in a counter-attack against
the us
now is not the time for our general to
come out and say
i am pathetic and weak and have no
have no strength of will of my own mind
well the problem is that
xi jinping and putin they have youtube
and they saw that woke army and they
said
the lesbian mothers and they probably
invade today invade
and of course they were inviting the
aggression do you see putin praise
joe biden he's focused you got to pay it
you got you got to pay attention
and then i see these these these biden
voters on facebook being like
even putin's recognizing that joe
biden's strong republicans
are so are trying to make like
republicans want putin to win because
they hate biden so
much but even even putin recognizes
biden is is not
losing his mind and i'm like putin wants
to destroy us
and wants us to keep voting for the the
man who has no lucidity left
so that he can win a war so obviously
you had trump trump's foreign policy
whatever you think of the individual
incidents the genius of it of course was
you just
never knew what this guy was going to do
i mean he'd call do you remember he
called
kim jong-un short and fast
just because just cause he had insulted
i mean this is a pretty wild guy he
you know he took out the top general he
was called the dotard he was called
yeah that's right yeah and and so he
goes in
and you know but then he assassinates
iran's top general he drops
bombs and various blood but it totally
unpredicted right then he pulls some
troops out
with biden biden just is the avatar of
the liberal establishment right he is
he's just the same guy the
top brass in the navy talking about man
it's just whatever
is in the zeitgeist that's what biden is
and the the sad fact is
if you know that you're going to get a
traditional
liberal establishment foreign policy of
course you're going to aggress
in the south china sea if you're xi
jinping do you really think the american
people
are ready for a war to defend taiwan no
no
way not to get involved and i've i've
been advised
i think were you gonna say steve steve
yeah yeah he was explicitly like no no
we're not
it's silicon valley it's he's called it
silicon valley west we lose taiwan we
lose our computer chips no more trucks
no more cars no more computers
you think do you think the american
people are are
seriously concerned at the moment about
deterring
putin from further aggression and crimea
oh no
it's so far away if it was cuba yeah i
don't even know about that
i think they're so concerned about like
look
a general came out and said he's reading
mao
and and lennon and he's
having the troops study the the
real history to understand this country
wow yeah it's you just feel so
crestfallen
it's just it's so i mean we were joking
about how we need to make it even more
depressing but it does you know
i mean truly you've gotta on the first
step to recovery you need to recognize
that you've got a problem this this rot
runs so
so deep i don't i do still think there
is some hope i think there's a glimmer
of hope
because the american people are repulsed
by this sort of thing but they're really
depressed by it i think
when you see that russian military ad
where it shows like this
this super chat this rip super chad
shaved head
and he puts the hood on and then he's
like he's looking down he's all angry
and then he jumps out of the the plane
and parachutes and then he lands he's
got a bolt action rifle
and it's dark colors and it's like that
and then you're like whoa
yeah that's that's a tough that's it
then you see the other one where it's
like going to the parade and like
to be fair though that was an army ad
yeah and the marine corps ad
is still a bit more you know it's like a
guy he's walking down the street in a
cyberpunk future
and then an advertisement pops up saying
buy shoes and it's like
you know pointing out that people have
no purpose and then he falls forward
through the hologram and lands in the
mud and gets up and he's got a rifle and
they're like go
go go and then he's moving through the
woods that was a bit more on point with
war and conflict yeah so maybe the army
is looking for administrators and the
marine corps is looking for warriors
but but right now i mean that's that
actually does give me a little hope
right and i'm sure
the marines are gloating over this
but but you know even among
conservatives right now
so-called conservatives they're going to
be people who say well you know i think
actually if
a transgender person wants to observe in
the military that's perfectly fine
well you know i think women should be in
combat positions and well i think you
just think
oh oh so you're not serious about this
either i don't think that there is
anyone advocating for trans soldiers in
putin's russia or xi jinping well but
i don't i don't i i if somebody wants to
uh
go shoot the bad guys i don't care who
they are what they think they are
i don't know you may identify if if a
guy thinks he's a woman
and is demanding really crazy medical
treatments
and it clearly doesn't have his grip on
reality
i don't think i want that guy in the
military call call me an extremist but
it seems like there's a problem there's
some logic to you know you want
sane strong people next to you
in in combat if they fall then you're
you have no protection on the side and
by the way you know the reason i don't
want women in combat
is not because i don't think women are
perfectly capable obviously they're not
as physically strong as men which is why
they're losing all the weight lifting
competitions now including including in
the olympics
two men but it's because i think it's
wrong for society
to send its women to go fight i think
it's disordered i think men and women
are different
i think we have different roles we are
complementary we're not identical and i
don't want to live in a world
in which i've got a lovely graceful
woman
fighting my wars for me well so so the
issue comes down to
um i guess what's the right word
you've got by any means necessary
victories
and moral victory if you have a country
that says
we will send wave after wave of our own
people we don't care who they are how
tall they are with their man if they're
a woman or they're trans they're gay
they're straight whatever
we will give them a gun and send them
your way but don't you think like
the fact is women are just not as strong
i this is not insulting to women it's
just a natural fact
and so if you've got an army of all big
tough dudes who look like super chad
from the russian ad
that is going to be a stronger army than
a mixed army with women
but but that that's under the uh
assumption that we
lose some of our uh servicemen
by adding service women you see what i'm
saying like if we have let's say we had
a million
uh well-trained well-world machine
marines and then we're like we got this
hey we also got a hundred thousand women
that's just a benefit in my opinion well
i mean but we're also not
we're not napoleon's army we're not
launching these you know million person
land wars
and i suppose one of the arguments i'm
not saying that women have no role in
helping out the military i just
specifically i'm talking about comments
oh historically you have a few women
like thomaris was a scythian queen
and she was a warrior queen and
basically stomped out the persians
more or less um you had like boudicca
who was a celtic queen that fought
against the romans
so you get these i don't know if they
were like beastial monstrosities
monster humans i don't know but they
were apparently fire like warriors like
they would slash and kill and
yeah but i think generally what you're
talking about is more of a general
effect
that one can name them i think is kind
of i think the idea
from the modern military in that regard
is how do we add more people to combat
roles it's like well women aren't
serving can we get them to serve
sure but do we increases the number do
we have a shortage of of fighters i
don't think so i mean we don't you know
the first of all the wars we wage are
mostly from like
office buildings in new jersey where
we're fighting with video games to blow
up bad guys in in uh
syria but i don't i if we had a genuine
shortage of people who were able to hold
a gun and shoot it then i suppose that's
a conversation
i think it comes down to this for me um
we should have a standard
you should have to pass that standard
they shouldn't reduce the standard for
anybody
and so i think that's one of the issues
people are concerned about is of course
yeah i mean
they're they in some circumstances some
uh departments and like fire departments
and police have lowered standards
in in all circumstances virtually right
i mean but so that's a problem too
but i'd like to take it even further
let's say that there is a woman you know
some great ancient queen who's an
amazonian who's you know destroys the
virgin army
uh all well and good i still think just
as a social matter
as a matter of the way that men and
women interact with one another is a
matter of chivalry darn it
the age of chivalry is gone that of
saufesters economists and calculators
has succeeded it and the glory of europe
is extinguished forever to quote the
great edmund burke
i think that's bad i want the glory back
i want the chivalry back i want
i want a world in which men and women
are not seem to be identical or
indiscernible
or at odds with one another i mean one
of the one of the arguments that is that
there will never be a war with between
the sexes because everyone's sleeping
with the enemy
i want them to be complimentary again
and that requires people observing
certain limits both men and women yeah
very unpopular view i suppose but
i think it happens i think what ends up
happening is
people start scraping the bottom of the
barrel in their conflicts and things
just
get weird i will say i will say one
thing um a lot of what we talk about
especially when it comes to like women
in combat and um you mentioned obscenity
laws
yeah we wouldn't need laws or policy
if people had a shared moral framework
within their culture or
it would certainly would not be nearly
as necessary because
but but again the law kind of reflects
the culture right
and but the law also influences the
culture jordan peterson talked about
enforced monogamy
and immediately these leftists were like
assuming he was saying women should be
like physically forced to be in
relationships with like nasty men with
me
yeah yeah with you but what he meant was
correct me if i'm wrong so i think
you know lydia might you know you might
know this what he meant was just there
were societal pressures
that you were in a relationship you had
an obligation and
if you didn't uphold your your your
contract then you were looked down upon
that right is that was that that's
correct and when jordan peterson made
this point i don't know if he realized
this at the time but he was tapping into
something that's absolutely pivotal
you need cultural pressure for the
things that you want you need it against
the things that you don't want
that way the government is not required
to for example censor speech
they can let other people do it oh you
shouldn't have done that mom says it to
him
you know i guess i i agree with jordan's
point i agree with what we're talking
about
but this distinction this neat
distinction between politics and culture
i think is a little blurrier because
when cultures and societies come to
certain decisions
let's say they want to pass blue laws
and you can't buy booze on sunday let's
say they want to ban porn or
prostitution or something
they come together and they have the
social more and they reflect that in
their law
and so these earlier ages which had
perhaps a more
moral and upright or at least virtue
conscious people
also had much stricter laws about
obscenity and these sorts
but most people didn't need the laws
right it's it's an interesting conundrum
how that occurs
and the laws in part form the people and
the people form the laws of course it's
very
very blurry there's a really great meme
where it's a guy on his knee
opening up a ring for a woman and he
says will you enter into a a government
contract with me that guarantees you get
all of my stuff and you can also leave
it at any time
that's how i think by the way that's
that's a really important point though
it used to be that you could not get
divorced like the judges would
be a judge would be like you need to go
to counseling
yes you will you cannot divorce and and
you know now i i know that it is
unthinkable that we should possibly make
our divorce laws a little more
restrictive
but of course we should the the societal
breakdown that has really ramped up over
the past
40 50 years is a direct result of no
fault divorce
it has ruined people's lives it has
destroyed society
if a a marriage bond means
nothing which practically i mean this is
your point and i'm not even
i'm not even just blaming the guys or
just blaming the girls it's it's set up
in such an unfair way
but if that bond means nothing then you
don't have trust as a society that is a
sacred value you're making not just
before god
that's pretty important too but it's
also a political matter you're making it
before the public and you're saying we
will be in this bond
if you can just dissolve that
willy-nilly then your social trust
evaporates thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time